think about the economic consequences of  how we're intertwined 22 of american  manufactured goods imports come from  china  so  um just imagine china became a like  russia in other words you say i don't  want to take imports so people don't buy  their nikes they don't buy their apples  they don't buy things that are produced  in china and so on do you know what that  would mean economically for us in terms  of the inflation rate and the  consequences because of how they're  injured the argument would be it hurts  china more we say but you say no  destruction right  who cares if it hurts china more yeah  right is that a win when you when it  hurts you terribly okay so both when you  have a war both sides lose